Bacteria is everywhere. Literally. In
the ground, on the subway, in and on your
body. I mean we are mostly made up of bacteria.
There’s more of them then there are of us.
For every one of our cells, there’s ten
bacterial cells.
The most bacteria in the body can be found
in the gut. Which isn’t all the surprising,
there’s been a lot of research lately about
the microbiome, the ecosystem of bacteria
that lives in and on us. One small study published
in the journal Science found that other bacteria-laden
areas of the body include your palms, behind
your knees, and your feet. But the most diversity
on your body? That can be found on your found
on your forearms. Weird right?
But it’s not just in and on our bodies.
It’s AROUND our bodies. We literally walk
with a cloud of bacteria everywhere we go.
Kind of like pigpen from Peanuts. In a study
published in the journal Peer J researchers
captured air surrounding participants. They
had people sit in boxes for four hours and
measured the air around them. They found they
could identify thousands of types of bacterial
DNA and could tell whether the person was
male or female!
So basically you can get someone else’s
microbes even when you’re just standing
next to them. Great. That’s gonna make commutes
awkward.
So once that bacteria leave us, where does
it go? Well the most bacteria laden places
tend to be places like public transit.
One really cool study of recent years was
a massive undertaking by researchers at Weill
Cornell Medical College. They swabbed thousands
and thousands of surfaces of the New York
City subway system. A system that sees nearly
5.5 million people per day passing through
its stations and trains.
Their findings were published in the journal
Cell systems. In total they found DNA from
more than 15-thousand different life-forms.
Almost half of the DNA belonged to bacteria.
But I should say most of the bacteria they
found is harmless. Only 12% were linked to
disease.
But it’s not just in public, it’s at home
too. There’s millions and millions of microbes
in nearly every nook and cranny of our homes.
And one study published in the journal Science
analyzed the homes of seven families over
the course of a few weeks. And they found
something surprising. The people seemed to
make the bacteria. Like when three of the
families moved, it only took one day for their
new house to look like their old house, microbially
at least.
And bathrooms. Man, bathrooms. Bathrooms are
pretty gross. But not as gross as you’d
think. Turns out your bathroom is dominated
by bacteria from… your skin. Yeah, not what
you’d expect. Yeah bacteria from your bum
like Roseburia and Blautia and bacteria from
other nether regions like Lactobacillus and
Anaerococcus are present in restrooms. But
only briefly. Bathrooms are too cold, too
dry, and oxygen rich to support growth of
these kinds of bacteria. Instead 68-98 percent
of the bacteria the researchers found came
from skin and from outdoors!
So the germiest place in your home isn’t
the toilet. One study published in the Journal
of Applied Microbiology found that it’s
the kitchen. Especially the areas that remain
moist like the kitchen sink which gets touched
a lot. The study found that the sink can have
nearly 100,000 bacteria per square centimeter.
Where the toilet only has about 100. and let’s
not even mention the dish sponge. ugh. They
have the highest concentration of bacteria
of any place in the home. GROSS.
But bacteria gets a bad rap. It’s not all
bad! In fact some of it’s pretty good for
us. Research shows that being exposed to more
bacteria actually bolsters our immune systems.
Seriously, there’s theories out there that
say we’re actually too clean in our environments
leading to modern diseases like asthma. And
it’s just as much a part of us as anything
else. So while if I were I’d toss out the
dish sponge right now, a fine balance of bacteria
seems to be just what the doctor ordered.
But the dish shop isn’t the only thing that’s
covered in bacteria, you cell phone is pretty
freaking gross. Check out how gross in this
episode right here